whatsapp ragazzi benvenuti questo nuovo
episodio di residenti vero che basta
fare dell'intro strane facciamo le belle
a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti basta perché
è sempre così dopo fa allora visto che
non ho ancora dato un'occhiata al
corridoio vediamo se spero andare nelle
altre stanze che sono la postazione
delle infermiere
c'è una cassaforte lì che non ho idea di
come prendere però vabbè cosa
solo nel cortiletto era molto facile
arrivarci posta a buttarsi dal primo
piano ragazzi dovrebbe esserci la chiave
quindi lo so dove
no non fare olio cuore ecco la staffetta
c'è qualcosa qui entrare però non mi
fido c'è un fermi contro secolo lì in
altre herbet facciano robe di da salta
ma non posso saltare pezzo di me allora
vediamo se adesso si alzeranno
ovviamente tutti quanti no ok non mi
fare scherzi tu style a ecco allora
vediamo se l'acqua dietro tutto sto
casino ma saccà
dei camici e quindi tutto sto casino per
cosa questo secondo me non è morto mai
però proviamo lo stesso è morto o il
badge santo iddio meno male perché non
sapevo cosa farci contenti fatti pensa
se c'erano solo proiettili a quest ora
ma si alza la propria porta si alzano
tutti questi senza pure quello questi
non si sono alzati mai stata una fan c'è
pensate due anni a cerca di capire che
cacchio devo fare qua
e invece poi alla fine l'ho fatto molto
bene ciao
no no no no no è sbagliato gioco no zio
no no non ho detto chi cazzo sei è una
trasformazione di ben ten giudizio scusa
è esattamente cosa devo usare di armi
contro non so cosa usa riga granata per
forza ma non morirà mai morto
aiuto aiuto l'altra stanza corri corri
qua dentro torri questo devo fare qua
mica estratta che si
vabbè che cazzo si limiti a tekken cosa
succede come ha fatto come ha fatto non
lo chiedo come è possibile come può un
essere umano
minchia speriamo sia servito perché non
vitali come scappare dal servizio come
ho fatto ragazzi non è stato così posso
entrare nell'archivio si lamenterà qua
almeno almeno qui
porca [ __ ] fatto malissimo e niente
ragazzi è tutto a posto
non solo caso non sto capendo ma paniere
come lo faccio fuori quello niente
dispare un miliardo di proiettili veri
rimasto lì ho buttato la granata in
tutto sto casino per chi se ne frega
deposito andate dove andare e portato
infermiere che tanto è ancora piena di
gente sicuro dove la gente ecco lo ha
posto a posto meno male che non ho
beccato nessuno perfetto
dai dai dai oggi però io non mi segua
ma basta a ce ne sono altre minchia non
regalare come faccio ragazzi non mi fate
scherzi che non posso farmi fuori mai
neanche per sbaglio nono armi per farli
fuori ciò questa ma non vi fate niente
come spararvi pop corn speriamo che non
venga di qua non so cosa fare se non lo
sa perché non ho idea di come farlo
fuori laga vi giuro
sono in una situazione
allora [ __ ] coro tp a spallate
corro dentro fuori dentro forti ten e
totti ten è come se non esiste bava sì
certo è che vai bravo fi bravo che cazzo
sei minchia bravissimo tira e toni così
bravissimo tirapugni tirapugni
va bene va bene non ti ha fatto niente è
solo un graffio mammamia continuamente
le bravo bravo ma perfetto ragazzi ok
bis era semplice cappotto cartoni in
bocca quel ma com'è possibile tutto
questo è impossibile
no c'era l'altro non sempre mi piaceva
altro se non fosse stato per questo ci
avrei fatta lega c'era quello di prima
porca vacca ce l'avevo fatta peccato non
mi fai partita quando c'e la
videocassetta video l'audio cassetta
bene scegliere mannaia avevo fatto delle
robe incredibili
non so neanche come poterle rifare però
va bene celo celo celo poi ci sta di
nuovo questo mi butto giù fuga stavolta
al giorno ma contenuto della carta iena
volta son morto fatto sto di vita
neanche troppo male ma anche troppo ma
allora vediamo se riesco a fare il giro
fatto bene da sotto devo salire di sopra
ho fatto tutto un giro tutto strano però
a ma forse mi conviene andare dove che
devo andare adesso questo cerca una dia
cassetta cielo adesso la portoricana il
mangianastri quindi combina con
mangianastri ok dinamo che sta dove va a
destra
urca vacca aiuto non era questa la porta
dunque fa niente entro in tanto qua per
chi invece è successo un casino da fuori
permesso cosa c'è qua dentro
prendi tutto come puoi prendere che non
ho capito cosa devo fare
allora devo andare dov'era l'ufficio
dello zio e l'altra volta che non mi
faceva incontrare vi ricordate non mi
piace entra e soprattutto è questa sala
d'attesa laboratorio qui qui qui devo
fare devo farmi quel corridoio con il
corridoio non so parla non è vero iolo
madonna sono morti tutti sicuro quasi
sicuro non sono per niente sicuro
ragazzi perfetto audiocassetta può
eludere il sistema di sicurezza laica
boss
dio mio sai con chi stai parlando io
sono nata di harvard calcio adesso siamo
è perfetta io sono alleati è nata nel
bar di cazzo parola chiave azzeccata
perfetto già salve signor nathaniel bard
lei
ecco perfetto parte è morto gli hanno
sparato
chi ha sparato ma sto cercando cerca
meglio guardare nel suo pc
va bene occhio alla gara che si può
trasformare in zombie non ha sparato
quindi tutto il suo bordello al pc e
quello credo sia questo con lo sfondo
della brella sono in possesso di una
sola dose del vaccino per il virus il
sacro graal non lo tengo per me o per la
mia famiglia o per le mie amanti o no
greche voglio darlo a te sto meglio di
chiunque altro con tutto sia il futuro
il nostro paese ma se lo vuoi gravi dove
prima telefonia questo inferno adesso e
senza che l'ombrello lo scopro poi
persona spettacolo so che potrei farlo
vedi se riesco a inviare una squadra di
soccorso senza piombo bcs come si dice
una mano lava l'altra memoria viva la
memoria di tutti quei festini che
abbiamo fatto assieme magari una mail da
berlusconi ma ti prego fa presto non ho
più tempo molto tempo nate e quindi poco
dietro ore 23 sono consapevole
spero davvero che questa registrazione
porti a galla la verità da jamie uno
possa essere in parte riabilitato ma
però l'incubo di raccon city è iniziato
diffusione di un'arma biologica nota
come pianisti
ha creato è stata l'azienda per cui
lavoro l'umbrella corporation e ha
ordinato a note di sviluppare un vaccino
e ci siamo riusciti
alcuni sono qui nel mio ufficio e il
resto nella struttura sotterranea ma
quegli stronzi dei piani alti vogliono
distruggerlo
non vogliono si sappia cosa hanno creato
e per questo stanno eliminando ogni
prova dell'esistenza del virus non sono
un idiota
so che non mi lasceranno o ok la mia
reazione dopo che ho registrato un video
e non registrato l'audio uguale va bene
allora va bene una sega però fa niente
come dovremmo arrivare dagli spettacoli
ricordo il passaggio all'accettazione a
trio nell'atrio core devo arrivare nel
all'accettazione prima gara i bilici
passera non è vero devi toglierti meno
male no come ha fatto a sprintare così
tanto quello accettazione vai vai vai
entrata
è pieno di gente non era cielo tutta sta
gente prima che cacchio non c'era tutta
sta gente prima nega che è successo
curati cura ok bene quali madonna di
giuro non c'era tutto sto bordello prima
detto ok ok siamo arrivati
mio dio presto storage il sono a posto
in cambio di questo mi dovrei dare il
grimaldello per aprire le porte perché
effettivamente quello serve un sacco
però se ce l'hai tu non lo posso usare
io quindi
spesso non ti aspettare che faccia
affetto ho capito ma il mic affetti in
un secondo
ci aspetta un attimo ok
a sei messo lì è seduto a dormire ok
nicchia triste che cazzo è successo
attenzione cittadini la rapida
diffusione dell'infezione è diventata
incontenibile
il primo dove tra così ci verrà
distrutta da un attacco missilistico e
le cattive notizie invece da domani ci
piace ancora gente crede che arezzo se
ne frega ecco che tu rimani qui ci penso
io no ma che ci penso io no perché ci
penso io perché ci sono queste scene
ci sono anche quelli grossi dai ma
quanto sisti cosa ci penso io ma tu
sorella ci pensa pezzo di culo o dio
santo sempre questi dementi dove lavora
allora fame beccari come non ho
proiettili cosa ci penso io a fare a
meno che non sono spronati da sponda di
proiettili non è stato uno spray medico
perfetto
proviamo a chiudere le serrande
come facciamo
ok
faccio io
nei mesi scorsi
che ovviamente non è morto ragazzi cosa
vi aspettate
ci sono anche un detonatore e grazie ad
esso è una specie di arena contro di
johnny b.good
i ragazzi ci prova ma sono veramente un
sacco non lo dico per fare questa cosa
non posso tenere tutti gli angoli
minchia arrivando a ovunque però forse
la cattedra può darmi la maschera del
demonio non provare usare anche le
stordenti e ragazzi che qua mi sa che mi
servono meno male che un sacco di
consigli al n 4 peccato che faccia
cagare abbiamo finito a venir sta
andando giù perfetto nel 7 fatte fare
non è fatto niente
usa una granata fa quello che vuoi una
granata lanciata dai rosa pur sacrosanto
i bio però vi era un sacco di
soddisfazioni zarate granata fermi
[Musica]
meraviglioso
ho già fatto già fatto a posto io non ci
fossi io guarda ancora con l'esclusiva
fuori porta
il che porta sta parlando che non ho
capito a questa volta di nulla e se
mancano un tipo 29 secondi rose bowl
oddio poi processo successo se ne era
mangiata per un attimo è ora sto attento
con a stordente sto facendo fuori un
miliardo in compenso provano più granate
meno male che mischiano stordenti
perché non mi batto quindi da questa
sorgente me la sono filata in faccia
sono un idiota o ciò teoricamente
dovrebbero l'estate dovrebbe stanarli
fino alla fine vediamo sono di colpi che
non ho preso nulla se non fa niente di
fatto
madonna
beh però allegro almeno quello tutto a
posto è per carità segno di morti
viventi
sì tutto a posto sono quasi morto
neanche per il caso della filippo re
apriamo che fanno ok è stato veramente
figo il mondo era così difficile pensavo
peggio
bene ma dove vai
non è finita che pensi di fare la città
verrà polverizzata avanti ti chiama il
governo di loro che abbiamo una tura
guadagna tempo
certo che le palle è per questo che sta
seduti tanto alla fine del mondo quindi
già che ci sei mobile è sopravvissuta
otto volte al nemesis
meno male che gliel'ha detto il la
televisione sono un immigrazione ma
l'altro dove il tipo che sta di fianco a
me dov'è allora ragazzuoli vediamo di
fare le cose fatte bene devo riuscire a
prendere carlos è sparito spariti tutti
non c'è più nessuno
buongiorno notte di qua ma a volte la
vita proprio per niente affatto tutto
carlos quel pazzo figlio di [ __ ] ti
ha portata qui e ti accurata dove adesso
nei sotterranei barda teneva lì in
vaccino la città può essere salvata
crede di farcela da solo devo
raggiungerlo ma non hai sentito il gol
la città sta per essere spazzato
ambiente sto provando a contattare
qualcuno abbastanza in alto per fermare
lascia fare a lui è un professionista lo
sono anch'io
ehi guarda che come faccio ad andare nel
sotterraneo anno e questo il sotterraneo
va bene mentre che vedevo lì e quindi
questa era la porta per entrare si
parlano male
non male che non ho buttato di mandello
permesso
carlos giovanni dove sei
io non ho capito non ho veramente capito
se poi alla fine ci sarà una parte dove
puoi giocare solo con carlos no perché
qui ci siamo intervallati quindi non è
come le altre residenti vol che puoi
giocare prima uno poi l'altro no
assolutamente no dato che cacchio di
sotterranei sono per un ospedale ok che
sono della umbrella groma dio c'è un
sotterraneo in un ospedale c'è un
sotterraneo così ma vi pare ma cos'è è
la cosa più strana del pianeta diamo
servono i sotterranei con la liscia domo
gestì mentali chi era e cosa far la
parte share sia mai d'accordo appunto
mica era roba che mai è come se sotto
camera mia ci possa l'umbrella può
essere quanto ci fate che mi spunta
almeno esiste la fine con lei non faccio
nient'altro che combattere il nemesys
quindi quasi quasi non usano anche le
mille lanciagranate questo tanto alla
fine tutti i proiettili creduto ai primi
nemesis che io di oh sì sì sì sì sì
bellissimo bellissimo
qui i ragazzi questo era il quarto è di
soli residenti con il prossimo sarà
l'ultimo spero vi sia piaciuto
[Musica]